let's talk a little bit about
exocytosis which is how the cell is able
to release
larger molecules that might be used by
the rest of the body other cells or
maybe it's going to be part of the
extracellular matrix and to understand
how this works it's really the reverse
of endocytosis we're going to go
and produce some proteins in the
endoplasmic reticulum this is our
classic example those proteins are then
going to bud off in their own little
vesicles which then merge with the golgi
apparatus where they are further
processed so they're processed in the
golgi apparatus right over here and then
eventually they're going to butt off of
the golgi apparatus in new vesicles and
those vesicles are going to make their
way over to the cell's outer membrane
the plasma membrane and the the
membranes of the vesicles are going to
merge with the membrane of the cell and
in doing so they're going to release
their contents and this is classic
exocytosis there are other cases where
maybe it releases it merges partially
releases the contents and then buds back
it's called the kiss and run method of
exocytosis but the classic one is it
merges with the membrane we can look at
this this membrane after it hit after
the vesicles membrane has merged with
the with the plasma membrane the
membrane might look like this
it might look like this so if the
vesicle let me do the vesicles membrane
in orange
if the vesicles membrane is that an
orange well now it has merged like this
and it has released its contents it has
released the protein to to be used
someplace else someplace else in the
body and i want to be clear this
membrane and i i've talked about it many
times in many other videos even though
i've drawn it as one line right over
here this is going to be this is going
to be a phospholipid bilayer so if we
were to zoom in
if we were to zoom in it would look like
this it's a phospholipid
bilayer
so these are some of the phospholipids
that were part of the original
or part of the original membrane and
then we also in my little box i get some
of the ones that are part of or that
were part of the vesicle that was
holding that protein
that were part of the vesicle that was
holding the protein so i really want to
stress i want to really stress these
lines that i'm drawing these are
bilayers of phospholipids and all of
these lines these membranes that you see
these are all bilayers of phospholipids
just to make sure just to make sure that
we are visualizing this correct and
that's what exocytosis is and one thing
that i find interesting is when you
first learn about it you see a diagram
like this and you just assume okay well
these bubbles of these you know these
membranes they just you know randomly
must float eventually to the membrane
and where they get merged and then they
release their their contents but it
actually isn't that chaotic they
actually can sit on tracks so they
actually can sit on tracks remember we
talk about the cytoskeleton which isn't
drawn enough probably because it makes
drawings really messy but whenever we
think about a cell there's all the
structure to it there's all this
structure to it microtubules
microfilaments intermediate filaments
all of these things over here that not
only provide structure to the cell but
they can be used to transport and these
vesicles these vesicles can actually
ride can actually ride on these
structures and you could actually have
motor protons motor not protons motor
proteins that are using atp to actively
push the vesicle containing its content
so this is kind of a transportation it's
it's really like a factory
to push them towards the membrane so
that they can be released so whenever i
think about it's fascinating because i
always talk about these cells being a
universe unto themselves and they aren't
just these blobs they have all of these
structures there's all of these proteins
that are really an unbelievably small
scale able to do these fairly intricate
processes so what i just showed you once
again this is classic exocytosis you'll
see it when you have proteins lipids
being produced by the cell that need to
be released somehow they're also
famously used in in neurons at when they
want it when you want the chemical
signal when you go from one neuron to
another you have exocytosis of neuro of
neurotransmitters that will trigger the
next neuron so these are very very
important processes our bodies would not
function properly if we or wouldn't
function at all if we did not have
exocytosis